Thanks I'm sure people have comments but
I actually wanted hopefully to ask David
I know David you're over there are you
paying attention to us could somebody
hit David I heard really liked to ask
David because cos David said you know I
think unique here possibly being well
this isn't totally fair but the most
experimentally oriented would that be
fair to say and so I think you have you
know a unique perspective whereas the
theorists really sometimes have to just
think it's completely at a meta level
about their work I think you know you
have a different perspective don't think
David thinking equals philosophy and
what you do is science well I mean I
like I think my CMOS and presentation is
very helpful goes right to the heart of
the matter for me which is it so I
learned a lot and it's been extremely
valuable but what I had hoped to learn
as it or take away as an experimentalist
is more about the putative continuity I
think you had ma Simone your prisoner at
the continuity between let's say
philosophy of science or philosophy of
mind and the things that I have to worry
about the lab scientists and that this
seems to me completely elusive so I had
hoped in the context of the discussion
but naturalism to really find let's say
conceptual alignments somehow between
the concerns we have in the bench or
whatever you'd like to call that and the
concerns you have and I didn't feel that
at all is it's not clear to me what I'm
supposed to take away as a practitioner
that changes how I do my business in
terms of you know experimental design
for instance and what types of questions
am I supposed to address in which way to
deal with the challenges of naturalistic
inquiry so has that chance
it has regrettably not changed my mind
about how you know what kinds of
questions I can address how to address
them and that's that's what I what I
wanted I guess I wanted a closer more
specific
alignment its curiosity-driven because
how can we put our heads together and
figure out how your philosophical
concerns can merge with what we can
actually accomplish to come up with kind
of mechanistic causal stories about how
stuff works and that's not yet there and
that's that would be my gurney as it
were here's one one suggestion that's
pretty close to you actually the bunch
of experiments that were mentioned and
never carefully described we're been
libbets
work and then soon at all there's a
whole lot of it and some of us believe
that those experiments are badly done in
the first place at least livets were and
what the scientists said about them
we're extremely naive theoretically and
that there's now the problem that a lot
of non scientists here these
proclamations by scientists not by
philosophers about the implications of
this work and that are that are ill
founded and it seems to me here is an
area where where where
experimental scientists if they think
they've found something that is of shall
we say philosophical importance and they
may I certainly think there are a lot of
experiments that really undo traditional
philosophical ideas are important well
that's been my stock and trade over the
years really is pointing these
experiments having sort of rubbing
philosophers noses and some of them but
I don't think those experie I don't
think the limit experiments are our
cases in point but very but then there
is a question about what should the
experimental scientists do when they
think they've uncovered something of of
more than interest just to their
particular experimental discipline but
they think it has a sort of
earth-shaking
results I agree with this
that's funny example another one for
which I could say my own work it's been
a philosophy is pitches analysis of
evolutionary psychology
I think philosophers have the tools to
be able to the analytical tools to be
able to see whether a conclusion follows
from certain assumptions that scientists
aren't trained to do so the way I think
about the evolution of human behavior
has been changed by these philosophical
ruminations of course that's only
because phil is deeply acquainted with
evolutionary psychology that he was able
to do that but I think there's some a
set of ways of thinking about things
that scientists can benefit from and
puts the things really in our corpuses
we're supposed to do experimental
research maybe it's even good maybe it's
like libbets experiments not so good you
surely internally criticize those
experiments anyway anyway anyway so but
now the burden is is say well we think
it has interesting interpretation so
where I'm supposed to come running and
say wait sort of the logical good no Dan
Dan posed the question what should they
do that was verbatim your question and
and so you're repeating about what
should we do in your estimation
to laboratory work and naturalism as a
philosophical movement shares probably
universally its obligation to let what
you tell us the facts are lead
philosophical and the theoretical
discussion with the critical proviso
that of course we have to examine what
though what what the descriptions of the
laboratory results are but I'd like a
stronger burden I'd like you guys to
take us time into IIIi would like to
adopt the rich and you know well
reasoned philosophical traditions that
inform and decide on your experimental
agenda on the basis of where your
curiosity drives you not on the basis of
some extraneous philosophical view what
Alex let's I'm sorry just just um what
we do you know I mean experiment sizes
too often test a theory
sure and so in some sense maybe David's
asking are you promoting any theories I
can test in the lab would that be one
way of phrasing it are you saying in a
sense that you realize that's trying to
translate down you know a larger scale
position into you know am i measuring
this or that and might in my dishes and
but I mean I guess it would be nice to
find serve the cone of direction of
argumentation or the kind of data that
were for instance helping that's not so
I think
not the data that generated so the the I
mean it would be helpful to look let's
take the discussion yesterday afternoon
which was a little weird about meaning I
mean there's lots of stuff we know I
mean there's no great work in cognitive
psychology psycholinguistics linguistic
theory from the last 50 years a weak and
drawn that the - a pretty detailed and
we can test that stuff now there's
disagreements in this room about whether
that's important enough that would be
useful to know about is this kind of
position worth testing is this kind of
position worth testing in the way I then
develop the experimental details in a
quarry today so there I think that
alignment can be more closed than they
have seemed to me at the moment
you